it's been a question for nearly three
years where is Sharon beardle's body now
there may be an answer 8 news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy was in court
today where her killer made a startling
admission Vanessa Sasha Philip O'Reilly
finally admitted to killing his
girlfriend in July of 2020 and as a
condition of his plea agreement he just
revealed where he put her remains he
will also spend the rest of his life in
prison here's the 37-year-old man in
court earlier today he was facing the
death penalty but through the plea deal
that's off the table now he also was
fighting the case against him which
included charges for murder sex crimes
against children and child abuse and
then in March police say they caught him
in a murder for higher plot from jail as
he tried to hire another inmate to kill
four of victim Sherilyn beardle's family
members including two children here in
court today O'Reilly pauses before he
admits to the murder
ING colonistly with malice before
thought kill cherilyn bird all the human
being said killing having been willful
deliberate and premeditated and or
perpetrated by means of torture
yeah
the other charges are expected to be
dropped as a result of the plea deal
O'Reilly is set to be sentenced in June
since he just revealed where he put
beardall's remains this is still a
developing story we've learned her
family is aware of his Revelation Sasha